everybody thank you all for coming
we were a bit on tenterhooks for a while
we thought we weren't going to be core
but then you all flooded in so good
morning oliver
um so we know i caught from
both sides
before i start the meeting proper i will
just
read out the
rules of the day
welcome to this joint order and
standards committee i am councillor bryn
haron and i am chairing the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and in the social areas please
ensure that you wear a mask unless when
you are moving around the building
once you have taken your seat you may
remove your mask please ensure that you
use the hand sanitizer and the wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during
any break
please ensure that your microphones are
turned off when not in use and that you
do not interrupt other speakers
also if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the
modern.gov app
i would like to remind everybody that
this meeting will be broadcast live
on the internet and will be capable of
being repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you were also consent into being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of these sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purses
purposes
the council members of the public
and the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
now i'll just make the introductions for
today
uh the officer's attendant our emily
yule the monitoring officer thank you
for coming emily catherine steele
um we don't have melissa evans i don't
think
john snell the corporate
manager for internal audit
and instead of mandy we have henry at
holloway who's going to keep us
all in order today thank you henry app
now no move to the agenda
[Applause]
can we have apologies for absence
henriette please and substitutions if
there are any
yes chair good morning we have received
apologies from councillor none
thank you
do i have any declarations of
procurement or non-bikini interests by
any of the members
now we'll move on to item three
confirmation of the minutes
um
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes i will sign them
after the meeting obviously but just for
good order
is there anything from those present
last time that
you were not happy with
okay can i have a proposal please
mary and the second day will be dave
thank you
okay we'll move now to the electronic
votes
mr uh the vote is now in progress on
your app
okay i'm done
that's fine counselor american and i can
take your vote verbally
four okay thank you chair that's seven
votes for
thank you henriette we'll move on to
item four
notification of petitions do we have any
none of the chair
thank you
and questions by the public none
received and questioned by councillors
non-received chair
thank you well we moved now into the
main body of the meeting which is item
seven
gaac 21-6
the risk register report and the
management activity
and um
that's down to jon snell to present john
can we bring you in here please thank
you
okay thank you chair and good morning
councillors um
i thought i'd take this as an
opportunity because there's some sort of
new people relatively new to risk
management i thought i'd take this
opportunity just to actually give you an
overview of the processes that we we
adopt throughout the council so
to provide that um
so the council's
risk register is reviewed by the senior
leadership team where each risk is
detailed in terms of its cause
what's causing the risk the risk itself
and the consequences of of that risk
we have a risk matrix switch
where scoring is applied in terms of the
likelihood of the risk happening and
also the impact it will have
against the councils
mitigations are also put into place
where these are possible to reduce the
risk to the councils and the risk
exposure across both both organizations
there's also an opportunity when slt
meet to
look at potential
new risks and also emerging risks
which are also discussed
and taken appropriately where action is
needed
each of the risk is owned by a member of
slt and following each review of that
risk register they will
liaise with their respective cabinet
lead to ensure that they're up to date
on the risk position within their areas
of responsibility
part of the
review process is also to consider
de-escalating risks
where the mitigations in place that have
been reduced
can be managed at more of an operational
level rather than a strategic level
and underpinning all our risk management
processes that we have in place is the
council's risk management strategy
which periodically gets
brought to this council where there have
been significant changes where we would
need obviously your approval to to move
forward in those areas
on the in terms of developing the risk
register on the risk register itself you
will see that uh hopefully see that each
risk tells the story across the page
uh starting on the left from the initial
original scoring of the risk and that's
before any mitigation
is actually brought into play through to
the current position
and ending with the target score and
outstanding actions to help achieve this
score and the target score is where we
would like to be
once all those mitigations have taken
place
we're also looking to develop the risk
to ensure it provides the necessary
correct level of information
to allow counselors to make informed
decisions that's also from an officer
level but also from yourselves as
members
now recently we've asked for an
assurance review of our risk management
arrangements to be undertaken by our
internal audit provider tier who you're
familiar with
their draft findings at this stage have
provided a reasonable assurance opinion
in terms of what they've carried out the
findings and the recommendations as i
say this is only a draft stage at this
point and so this report is going to be
presented to slt
on the 4th of october for their
consideration and management comment
the actions that agreed from from that
meeting will be reported in my midterm
report to you back at this committee in
november
in terms of the risk registering report
itself um you'll see that um
that the risks in front of you are as a
august 2021
and it also includes the work undertaken
around risk management processes during
the year
you'll see that there are currently 20
risks on the register
of which 13 risk 13 and 17 have been
separated to reflect the different risk
levels scoring between the two councils
in summary there are 14 risks that have
been scored as medium
six have been scored as high
and two have been scored as very high
i've also included with a report and
i've like i thought i'd draw this to
your attention those risks seem to be
the top risks
facing the councils at any at this point
in time
although not not necessarily the highest
in terms of their scoring they are
considered to be the top priority in
terms of
slt and what their considerations are
in terms of operational risks
these registers are in place across the
service areas and they should be updated
at least quarterly
assistant directors liaise with their
representative corporate managers
uh regarding any potential risks that
may need to be escalated to the
significant risk and conversely
de-escalated from the significant risk
register to an operational risk register
in terms of other work
i continue to provide help and guidance
to support authors
on risk matters as part of the report
sign-off process
and i'm also a member of the public
realm working group
which is tasked with unifying the
service delivery arrangements across
both councils
with responsibility for managing and
monitoring those risks
in terms of moving forward and i haven't
actually reported this
but currently we're looking um to
combine performance risk and finance
information into one report
which will not again help staff but also
members to help really understand the
correlation between those three
disciplines and obviously take actions
accordingly as i said it's not in report
because we're only just looking at it
but in terms of developing the risk
management processes and also the other
disciplines around finance and
performance
it seemed to be a very good idea in
terms of bringing it together at some
point into one report
so so you have that fuller understanding
of how the councils are operating
against performance
i think i'm just happy to take questions
at this stage uh chair
yes thank you very much john um i've got
a couple of areas with questions but can
i ask first maybe emily can come into
this as well um
my question is what difference can we
make um
i know you said it's gone to slt 4th of
october i think but
if we're not happy with this can or we
think we need to be something up can we
make those sort of
recommendations to slt or is this just
purely for us to say it's okay or not
okay what is your view on that
or
emily
yeah happy to take that chair yeah it's
very good um
in terms of reporting today
i'm very much welcome the thoughts that
you have in terms of the risk management
process it is developing is it is a live
document
if there are items or you there's a lack
of understanding from members in terms
of how this is actually reported to you
happy to take those thoughts on board
and i can feed those into the meeting
that we're going to have which also is
discussing the tiers report in terms of
how we can further develop it so
very receptive to any comments that you
may have and feed those through to slt
okay thank you john well that's that's
brilliant
the floor is yours then lads i think my
concern is obviously um
the monetary um
we may need to be fast moving which i
think you've covered actually
and the other one of course is um
meeting the climate change requirements
which
you know i have concerns especially on
planning
i think we could do so much more and
sometimes planning is taking us
backwards but they are my concerns but
um
as chair i shouldn't lead so i'll let um
people from the floor and in the order i
saw them it was council about councillor
mclaren councillor mueller so
um councillor barrett purse please
um so john from your comments are we
here just to look at the process that
you're involved or actually good content
sorry cancer it's actually the content
of the register itself
would just give you a context in terms
of the process on that basis then can we
look at risk seven
which is
workplace delivered
districts due to market failure and
availability of commercial property
is that what it is am i getting that
right
that's what's out there in the
marketplace is that what we're looking
at john
okay so i have a problem with uh because
it obviously mentions the joint local
plan and i know in sudbury the joint
local plan this is a concern i have we
have a allocation of an employment land
that's been now out overturned has been
made into what they call a non-allocated
so it's basically not
it's all white
um and this came forward from the from
the cabinet member
with support
from
the
robert hobbs
but
it was in direct conflict with the
economic growth team
because they wanted it retained as
employment land
i think that needs highlighting that
there is conflict there between the
realities
and the joint local plan
and that needs to be looked at
because
obviously mid suffolk don't have the
same pressures because they're bringing
forward gateway 14 which is a big
development which gets them out of jail
as that but baber we haven't got
anything really and
the amount of
commercial land availability and the
in our i think this is where the
district council
really should be making a difference
it's not that we want to be developers
but what we should be is enable the
conditions right for people then to
develop
and that's not coming through in the
joint local plan
and i think that's a considerable risk
so if we could highlight that
yes certainly council i can take that
back thank you very much
to tom and also fiona and while i'm on a
bit of a role mr chairman if i can
continue
item 13
sorry risk 13.
um
obviously uh
baber has
started off with a risk factor of 16 and
that's gone to nine now gone to eight
and that's presumably because you were
working on the rather inaccurate
forecast coming forward in the original
budget position or the out turn
that's subsequently now gone from a 1.8
million pound deficit or there are
thereabouts in september last year when
they were discussing the ford budget
it's now coming up to the out turn of
2021
where we have a
739 surplus
and presumably the risk factors there
have been adjusted accordingly although
we're still
looking at this in a in a significant
risk area because it's in a red and it's
an eight
so um
bearing in mind that the financial out
turn is considerably better
than was projected when you would have
seen these figures and presumably doing
your risk calculations on the initial
stages um i'm just wondering if if this
is still an accurate risk projection on
the basis of where we are
i think you'll hand that over to
catherine
it's been good management probably what
you're going to say but can you
enlighten us please
yeah
cancer is certainly right we had a
better than anticipated outcome position
for 2021 that was reported through to
cabinet uh in august
but we are still looking at a deficit
position over the next three years one
of the main reasons for that is the
uncertainty around new homes bonus um
the figures from moving from 21 22 into
next financial year is a reduction of
600 000 pounds in terms of new homes
bonus so that's a challenge for us if
the government doesn't review that
system they've consulted about it but we
haven't had the outcome yet
so i am hoping that we will get some
income in some shape or form to replace
that loss of income
and there would be another 200 000
pounds that would be
lost the year after as well so over a
period we can lose income which is is a
risk because we don't know how we're
going to replace that currently so would
that be in your estimation the worst
case scenario because in my experience
that the government do not
they they tamper with the figures
because they don't take away totally
those because obviously if they did it
would leave us in a very vulnerable
position and that would just be our
council it would be every council in the
country so there would be normally a
substitute which would be a performance
related income stream
that we would normally look to get so
your
figures are the worst case scenario
assuming no
replacement income stream because we
don't know at the moment so yes we're
waiting to hear what that might be
that's great thank you very much
angela mccarron please
thank you
trey
um thank you john for that paper and the
clarification at the outset of the
the presentation
um
i've got two questions upon nature
my first question is
when we're looking at risk management
and risk assessment
it really encompasses three aspects
where risks occur which is fit people
fit business and fit systems
and looking at this
risk
list
um
there is a lot of people element in
the risk
if you look at words like engagement
effectiveness and efficiency
they are the the people the risk
part the main risk part of these some of
these risks have been highlighted
what
action will we i think you partly
answered it in the presentation but what
action will you and assistant directors
be taking
recognizing the people risk is probably
one of the largest parts of
the problem
thank you councillor in terms of
resources and being able to
provide the necessary services that's
where sort of we're coming from
obviously
assistant directors meet regularly
one-to-ones obviously with their
corporate managers as well so they're
discussing sort of not only sort of
strategic issues but they're discussing
also the operational issues and it's at
that point where they're discussing the
the level of service that needs to be
provided part of that element is around
about having the right skill sets as
well and having resources to do that and
i think in terms of business continuity
and resilience their conversations are
continuously ongoing with staff and also
senior management as well so there is a
recognition that we still have to
provide those services
the the members of the public still want
a level of expectations quite rightly
and it's how we meet those
expectations and where we actually
put and our resources to to meet and
deliver those expectations so
what in terms of answering your question
it's an ongoing risk management is
basically an ongoing process it's not
something we just sort of stop and park
and then pick up again everything that
we do in our life and also inside of
work and outside is also risk-based
so in terms of the people element and
the health and well-being of staff
particularly with the kovid we need to
be very very mindful that we are
protecting our staff that allows them to
then provide those critical services
that we we deliver so they are sort of
ongoing
uh dialogue between staff at all levels
from the bottom right through to the top
so
it's not an exact science but those
conversations are constantly having and
part of that is reflected in the risk
register but clearly we need to sort of
be very very mindful um particularly of
late of having those
exact risks um
encapsulated in the register either at
significant or an operational level
that doesn't then expose the council
that we don't have those skill sets to
to provide the level of service that our
residents need
thank you and just
following on from that really and this
is a very practical question
thinking about the people element again
do we have the resources then and can
you reassure us
that
policies procedures
key performance indicators
would respond
to perhaps the changes
that are required yeah absolutely
through those uh discussions as i sort
of alluded to particularly you know at
the one to ones and appraisals etc
myself as a corporate manager and
obviously i've got my aed behind me so i
have to be careful what i say but in
terms of levels of staff if i'm feeling
that the service that i provide although
it's a support service that are being
stretched emily and i have those
conversations on a one-to-one basis and
regularly outside of those one-to-ones
if issues that come up that need to be
addressed and that goes through um right
through the organization the same with
catherine with her staff you know
obviously katherine you you've appointed
a couple of new members of staff because
there was a shortage we've got those in
place with those right skill sets so
once those issues and we feel a little
bit of tightening in terms of delivery
that's when we need to be mindful but
there's also horizon scanning so we're
talking about new and emerging risks if
we see resources as being one of them
then we that's flagged up obviously
senior management they talk regularly to
suzanne hughes from hr as well so we're
looking at again pay scales which i
won't go into details at this stage at
the moment but they're things to try and
attract and retain staff
so as i say it's an ongoing dialogue
that we're having but we're also very
mindful as i say that we can't be
stretched you know as i said resilience
is really important so when we're
looking at the staff you know who would
replace me who would replace a catherine
obviously when she retires in april so
that's already in process
could we replace catherine i could see
you saying
absolutely
so it's an ongoing process counselor
yeah
thank you john thank you chair
thank you
um council lamola please
sure
john i was particularly interested in
risk 15
further actions comments
staff flu vaccination program to be
introduced autumn 21 or once c19 covered
booster and flu vaccine program
confirmed by the nhs
i gather from reading that is this
something new that the council's
introducing and are you planning to
arrange a sort of mass vaccination of
members of staff in endeavor house if
they wish to take that offer up or how
do you plan to operate that
unfortunately jonathan free who's sort
of leading on this isn't here because
he'll be able to answer it far more
articulately than i can but certainly
we're very mindful obviously with the
current pandemic that we need to protect
staff and members and members of the
public as well so what we're trying to
do is encourage staff to again abide by
the government's guidelines so in terms
of obviously hand sanitizing distancing
masks etc that's an encouragement to
staff there are obviously periods where
we can't enforce but we're recommending
it to protect and the same with our
contractors when they go out on field as
well
so um
i don't know the full facts because
unfortunately jonathan is our sort of
guru
around that and actually uh implementing
that but we're sort of certainly abiding
by the guy the government guidelines at
this stage to protect all i think
yeah thank you chair uh say until very
recently i was chair of our tactical
management team um so i've been involved
in some of the discussions that we've
been having
we were acknowledging that obviously
some of our members of staff of a
certain age will automatically be
offered the the flu vaccine but it won't
happen across across the piece so we
were discussing whether it we should
offer it out to all of our staff those
who wish to take advantage of it i don't
think we've decided on the how but i i
am aware i think our colleagues in in
west suffolk are actually offering a
voucher scheme so people can then
obviously choose where they go to get
there to get their vaccination we
probably wouldn't go down the route of a
mass vaccination because we obviously
don't want that many of our staff all
together and then so obviously
increasing the covered risk of bringing
people together like that so so it could
could be either say so via a voucher
system let's say i think that's that's
currently being finalized
thank you catherine
um councillor lindsay
you chair um
yeah thanks for this
report john um
it is a good um
it's a good
mind exercise to sort of focusing on
what can go wrong
what could possibly go wrong
with that babe in mid-south district
councils um
obviously you won't be surprised i'm
interested in
the risk around
the climate crisis um i know we've got
one
in 18
um
that seems to just be talking about
one part of the motion which was
reducing the council's own emissions
but there was another part
where we had a goal to reduce emissions
across the districts
uh i think both councils had that
um
and obviously
that's a far bigger
we're talking about you know a
percentage of a percent
what what the councils emit compared to
what's being emitted
uh across the districts by
uh
homes leaking heat by
um
by transport by cars and so on
so i'd like to see
something put in about of that aspect of
it as well please
if that's possible
and also
does the
impacts of climate climate change
already here it's already with us as we
know we've seen from the floods
um
and so
something about
the risk of the impact of of climate
change on the working and functioning of
the council because if
if we cut i mean
i can imagine a scenario we have massive
floods
we can't get to people's houses to to
pick up their um bins don't do their
bins
um
you know as basic as that
um
i think we already partly
addressed it some of it by no longer
having to everyone having to go to
endeavour house to work
you know um
but i'm sure there are other things we
can do
to make ourselves more resilient
to the impact of
of all the things that could happen the
floods and the
um
god knows what else you know cues at
petrol stations how could that ever
happen yeah
thanks
yeah thank you uh councillor um just to
come back and it was something i think
the chair also raised around obviously
um the carbon reduction um as you'll see
under risk 18 you know the proof of the
carbon reduction management plan and
also the biodiversity action plan
what i'm proposing to do from an
internal audit point of view
is we have it in our audit plan to have
a look at that
so i'm talking with cass
cassandra clements the aed for that heir
in terms environment and leisure
services and partners
what i'm proposing to do is do almost a
bit of a health check against
that plan and then i can report that
back at some point obviously to this
committee but just to reassure you that
it is it's in our audit plan um i've
already had uh conversations with the ad
cass
responsible for this area um as i said
my intention is to do a bit of a health
check where we are against that action
plan um and do a sort of like a rank
status approach uh and then report that
back to this council at some point um
hopefully that will provide you with a
degree of assurance in terms of how
we're managing and operating and
implementing some of those actions
within the plan
something i forgot to to say really um
the the other i think our chairman
alluded to it that if we're it's all
very well if we cut our emissions as a
council but if we ignore the fact that
we're giving planning permission to huge
great housing developments that are car
dependent
then the public are going to look at
that and say well
you know you're just you're just feeling
at the edges so it's that planning
aspect and the fact of development
that's
that's important as well thanks
before i bring cancer ambrose and then
maybe i should make my comments it
wasn't so much about what we do as a
council it's what we can instigate
um across the whole area
and
i think when the climate
emergency was carried i thought it was
going to make
difference to lots of things and
i've been rather disappointed
i think very local to me permission was
given for
65 houses with a full school and
it relied on 200 000 pounds been given
by the developer to bus all the children
away from the village
for years and years to come and then
when that died out
it would all be individual cars because
the school is full you see
and i was so shocked that
councillors passed
totally against the
climate change emergency we just
declared it looked the biggest own goal
ever
and i think
if i could make a steer to planning i
would say that should under the
circumstances that should just never
ever happen
and i also felt that we miss
opportunities in planning to put
i think every commercial property that's
built
should have solar panels on the roof to
feed into the system and
i thought there was a way through
planning we could um
ensure that i'm not so fond of them
scattering all on our um
fields but certainly on
the bigger um industrial system we've
got acres of roof space we put them on
our council houses but we miss the
opportunity to um
put them on our commercial premises who
could produce huge and
i thought we would insist and instigate
things on that and planning you see and
that hasn't happened so
for me they are too
own goals you know um
i know i'm not sure if there's a bit
outside the remit of yourself
john or the committee but i certainly
think
we may not meet targets in other ways so
we certainly need to meet targets where
we can to it's a bit like weights and
measures and we do more of one to make
up from what we might do with another
using get there in the end and
if i could give a steer we probably need
a planning office in here but that's um
not been arranged but i certainly would
like to fly the plane for those two
issues and if anything can be
beefed up and
encouraged or done on that
it certainly needs um to go forward
i'm sorry council ramsey you may have
been on the same subject i may steal
your thunder but please come in now
thanks yeah sorry to be predictable and
reiterate
but just to say
yeah the fact that this is a risk
document which is otherwise uh
seems pretty comprehensive
the fact that it does seem to have a
blind spot for this uh
for the council's legacy in terms of
uh planning and and uh building work
that's go that is constantly going on in
the districts you know we're just we're
falling further and further behind in
our
objectives there because these houses
that are going up are you know that we
we know that they're not
using
um
the latest designs and technologies to
to ensure that we have a i mean and this
this section is called promoting and
actioning
a more sustainable approach to the way
we live and operate so i mean that's all
about infrastructure it's about building
stock and
um so i'm interested in what the two
the two sorry the two uh
the two largest emitters of the council
that have been identified what are they
um
i would have to come back to on that
council okay if i spoke to so i'm
guessing that one of them isn't
um you know
our planning legacy
uh and housing legacy yeah sorry
yeah rather than giving you an answer
so yeah just my two pennies on the same
same tech really
okay thank you council about it
um yeah it's interesting i do sit on the
planning committee and uh recently we
had a a a a letter from the chief
planning officer
to advise us that our aspirations
of the green credentials
are aspirations and until such times
they become law in the planning
guidance in terms of building
regulations
we can't impose our wishes at that stage
so until such times that becomes into
planning law
we can we can advise and we can rant and
we can stand our feet but it actually
has no meaning so
i can
totally uh take on board where my
colleague's coming from
but until such times that that's changed
into building rigs uh we can huff and
puff but we cannot blow the house down
so
at that point
we will obviously get on it but uh so
it's it's uh it's coming down the road i
mean they are changing the building
regulations and it will get to that
point where there'll be even more
sustainability there
but until such times that comes we sit
on planning and we are told that we
cannot put conditions on that are not
part of the law so that's where we stand
can i do it
mclaren yes it's just to support
councillor barrett i mean i'm on the
same planning committee
and the problem with plans is
as is mentioned as the risks is the
stall plans so we've got lots in the
pipeline
which may come and be developed after
we've got further on with our
climate change changes but i think
legally that we will still be restricted
by the conditions that were laid at the
original applications so i i agree with
council about it i felt very frustrated
when i heard that because it doesn't
help
us to change the
development of property thank you chair
thank you councillor norris please
thank you mr chairman uh page 15 related
to housing
under the further actions column it says
support for local housing needs surveys
six completed to date
and then plan completion dates
in that column under that it just says
ongoing i mean is it not possible to set
a target date for these housing needs
surveys to be completed because they are
quite important
thank you
yes council i can go back to the
relevant officer and see whether we can
actually be more specific in the dates
okay thank you councilor milo emerson
and caston in that order please council
miller thank you chair no i was also
going to agree with councillor barrett
and council mclaren because i too sit on
planning for mid suffolk and as he quite
rightly says we were given details from
the chief planning officer we can only
apply the regulations as they stand at
this moment in time but obviously they
will move forward once the building
regulations have been updated etcetera
council amazon
thank you
yeah i'm interested in this idea
that we
need to wait for
uh
national
regulation on
housing
because
what brings to mind is
when an individual or um
yeah when there's an individual
application for say
uh a new home
in an area of conservation or on um some
green belt land or to or an individual
house that's going to extend a village
there's very stringent um
uh regulations around that and
i think the guidelines say something
like um
you know it's got to be an exceptional
uh proposal
uh and it's got to have all you know
it's going to be looked unfavorably if
it has all of these uh green credentials
and and it's you know
maybe heat pumps and
passive housing it's good it's going to
be it's going to go through smoother
in an application for these individual
houses so
why doesn't the same apply to
developments
i think section 75 of the nppf now it
used to be
used to be 55. uh you're applying uh
against the standard local plan so it's
an exceptional site and you have
exceptional rules and that's how you can
get it through with an exceptional
design and with green credentials but
basically you have to separate within
planning you separate the planning
application for the
position of planning and then you have
building regulations building
regulations the technical side which we
obviously don't have any sale on and
that's why we're giving planning
permission to build a box
we're not really worried about the boxes
the building regulations make up the
difference with how that box is
constructed and that's statue
so we can't do it but if you want to go
outside the area which is what you're
suggesting you then have to come up with
a reason that uh the planning officers
could and us as a committee could be
able to give you that exceptional
circumstance so it's the is it the type
of land that isn't that's outside the
basic glp yeah so basically what you'd
be a is a you you'd be looking at those
sort of houses you talked about they're
not within our local plan they're
outside so their exceptions normally
right so
so obviously the council has sorry can i
carry on yeah so obviously the council
has influence on the on the jlp so is it
just a case of
being a bit meaner
as a council
well
i can let me speak for my view
the the the basic you you have pressures
obviously as we've just seen with our
own funding to deliver housing and we
get rewarded for delivering housing and
there's and if we don't deliver enough
houses it gets taken away from us
sure
but
um it just gets sent to the inspector
and there we're a bit off the subject
here i think
yeah this is more like a
philosophical
planning discussion it's development a
bit
tight to tight as the net sound through
the chair please before being comes for
cast and is this on the same subject
just sort of just say that
you're right we can huff and puff
and we may not the plan the planning
uh laws may not be there
but we should that doesn't mean we
shouldn't huff and puff we should have a
path
if we've agreed this we should stick to
it and it's important for people on the
planning committee to huff and puff as
much as possible
and actually the planning the the um
local plan that we have baby currently
has
uh has
um
rules in there about mitigating climate
change for new for developers and
reducing carbon impact which is one of
the reasons why the gas power station
plant at sudbury got rejected and
admittedly by only one bullet vote but
there are rules there and we do have to
have some puff
and it's all it's all a grey area but we
have to push
on that
thanks
yes exactly
uh yes emily please
thank you chairman and good morning
councillors um
obviously the conversation and the
debate is is very interesting but it's
slightly moving away from your
remit as the committee to look at the
risk
however what you might like to do is
make some recommendations to other
bodies to look into these issues further
so of course the cabinet is responsible
for the delivery of the carbon reduction
management plan so you may wish to alert
the cabinet to the fact that you've got
some concerns about the mitigations that
are included in the risk on the
significant risk register and ask them
to build
some of your issues that you've raised
into their performance management and
respond back to you
with regards to the planning
tensions if you like with
trying to stick within the the planning
framework but also delivering some of
those carbon neutral ambitions
because planning is a council function
that wouldn't go to the cabinet but you
could perhaps ask scrutiny to look into
it so you could ask your scrutiny
committees to have a think about
the extent to which our planning
committees can deliver on those
ambitions within that legislative
framework and they of course could call
the um chief planning officer in to
provide evidence in that regard
thank you chair
thank you for your input emily you've
taken some of the words right out of my
mouth let's see what council castner's
got to say because he may be on the same
subject or another then we'll come back
to it councillor custom a bit on the
same
subject um but that's not why my hand
was up but um i think um yes definitely
we've um we've looked into our our waste
collections our leisure centers and our
housing stock um
and um
i think now is the time that we start
looking into future developments and how
we're doing things and um
i think houses are being built and given
applications have been given planning
permission that are not ready for the um
net zero in 2030 and this is really
serious
we um
we've got the new home standard coming
through soon but
we need to we need to look at what this
authority and weber
can do to um so those homes and
buildings don't need to be retrofitted
at a later date a high expense and um
you know and
you know unnecessarily
retrofitted for things like gray water
solar panels on commercial property all
those things so i think yeah as a risk i
think we need we seriously do need to
consider this is a risk
um to this council but um
all i wanted to ask about is on page 25
um it's got um if we because if we fail
to protect our employees and other
persons to whom we owe a duty of care
and it's that
persons to whom we owe a duty of care
as a term that i wanted to one sort of
pick at a little bit because i i
understand it's not a legal term
um
you might tell me it is but um if it
isn't how do we define persons to whom
we have a duty of care in that
health and safety
risk management
thank you councillor
in terms of a duty of care i'd probably
have to go back to um jonathan free
who's responsible for that area in terms
of health and safety what i don't want
to do give you an answer where i don't
have any legal basis or standing to to
sort of to give you chapter and verse so
if you're a happy counselor i'll come
back to you to get a full definition of
exactly what that duty of care is and
how it's applied to um staff except as i
said i want to give you something that
is not quite legally sound or correct
and i'm sure jonathan will be able to
give me uh something to provide to you
yes thank you yeah that will be very
sensible
okay i'm happy with that any other
questions from the floor on this paper
councillor lindsay
well just to say that um our monitoring
officer was suggesting a
plan of actually
a couple of recommendations there
other matters
now i think from myself
i am a bit concerned about the financial
position um page 12
riff 19.
um katherine it almost sounds like a
perfect storm doesn't it um i was just
going to ask you is any of that money
that
we haven't collected
are we likely to catch up i think that's
what i'm asking
i think you're saying we've suffered
it's on page 12 just in the
in the general introduction
um
a significant impact on the council
finances and all the reasons but
is this going to even itself out as what
i'm asking is the money likely to come
back at a later point
uh yes exactly yes yes risk 19 yes
to be helpful
i'll then i'll try and answer some of
that that chair
um
the the impact of kovid is is still with
us and i don't think i could handle
heart sit here this morning and say you
know everything will will recover
because i think there have been changes
in behaviour
which will have some impact um just
thinking about you know people not as
many people are going into town centers
are they to shop so the level of people
parking in car parks and potentially you
know getting income is changing i know
our uh licensing income levels are down
because there aren't as many
applications coming in for for temporary
events you know and that's and you know
he's that sort of behavior change going
to continue so i think it's it's very
difficult to say that everything will go
back and we'll recover exactly we've
obviously had a lot of support from the
government in terms of a covid response
and we have had some more in this
financial year we had a lot last year
but the first quarter of this year we
had a further grant from the government
and they're also supporting us again in
terms of loss of self fees and charges
but i think some of the the longer term
impacts are a bit unknown at the moment
um you know things like that we talked
about it already the queues at the
petrol stations you know is is that to
do with brexit has it got some covert
implications so i think you know the the
world is still changing so i think it's
very difficult to give you 100
sort of reassurance at this point in
time
and you talk about the loss of income so
i presumed it meant that people were in
debt and couldn't pay the council tax
and things like that you'd say
and
you know i just wondered if we have a
plan to
recover that in the future
council tax hasn't been as hard hit as
we
anticipated so this time this time last
year we thought it would be a lot worse
um the shared revenues partnership has
been able to continue to collect a vast
majority of of what's owed but we also
know that the furlough scheme is just
about ending you know the end of this
month is is when the furlough scheme
completely unwinds so again that is
still a little bit of an unknown and the
government are obviously talking about
removing the the 20 pounds supplement in
terms of universal credit and i'm sure
that has helped an awful lot of people
in the country you know support them
with their with their bills like council
tax so there are still i think some
unknowns moving forward but you know we
monitor the situation very closely and
you know take actions or you know report
and adapt as we need to as that
intelligence comes through to us
it was also
i really
we've had to dip in reserves a few times
which i wasn't aware of but we had to do
what we have to do i understand and um
yeah okay
uh
thank you uh robert you were coming back
to um
tackle what we should do about the
climate change and the shortcomings
thereof
well
level i was just proposing that we asked
for another
um
just along the lines of what i initially
said it
was having an extra item in there about
the risk
not just to um
of
meeting you know the however we define
the council's
emissions but it's
it's the wider
um if we don't if we don't do anything
about the wider the emissions from the
wider community so we need to
put something in there about that
um
and
and also
the risks from the impacts of climate
change so that's two extra things
but i think
i mean
it's a recommendation to cat we have to
make it
you have to make a recommendation to
cabinet about that
the slt i think john said but he he did
say that he could um
make representation
representations to um the planning
officers i thought or and emily
suggested
um referred to scrutiny i'm not too sure
if um
given what we're up against this group
you could actually do um
much i don't know if you have a veil on
that um
do you have a view on that um
yes i i
i mean scrutiny is about achieving
outcomes
um
that's the principle you know it's no
good just sitting there discussing it
but as a chair of
babera scrutiny committee
i think i would like to review it
perhaps if perhaps i could make a
recommendation
but i think i would like to review it
with my co-chair
and emily and and if we scope it and if
there's no outcome to that then we leave
it alone but scrutiny is about achieving
outcomes
otherwise you just become a talking shop
yeah it's my first thought it's not much
good just keep talking about it is that
counter amazon
i think that's right that we don't just
want to be an echo chamber and uh
talk amongst ourselves i think
uh we've got to think in terms of length
and breadth so
let's think about
what outcomes we want
long term i know i know
we've got a time limit here um
but
what what would be the kind of
structural changes
in the future and further afield that
need to happen and i think
if the council
does
feel a level of frustration with the
state of affairs
then that's something that's got to be
communicated to the public
and
in no uncertain terms you know we've got
to say we
this is what needs to happen and
let the public make up their mind and
decide
what decisions they might have to make
uh in the future to to get the outcomes
that i think everybody wants
so i'd like to see some kind of outreach
of this i don't i don't want it to
disappear like you're saying let's stop
talking about it if we can't do anything
about it i want to
i want to amplify that message to say
that the council is hamstrung or
hands tied behind our back or whatever
it is
[Music]
and make it make it known yeah
[Music]
i think probably over to you john you
did suggest that we can make um
noises our concern to the planning
sector um i certainly suggest we should
do that if it's within our remit
i'm trying to look around you to see um
emily i think
just sending it to um
scrutiny it
probably just creates more hot air which
is what we're trying to get rid of
anyway isn't it
just advice please from
yourself john or emily
i think the
concern of the committee emily is that
um
we do have concerns that that area is
just not moving fast enough for us and i
think we just wish to send a signal
where we can that
we want that
element of the risk the risk of not
achieving what we said we'll do beefed
up a bit i think that's the steer i'm
getting from the committee and we're
looking for a way to sing it from the
rooftops a bit more so just looking for
your professional advice please
yes so i think there are two things um
there are two parts to a recommendation
around that i think one is a
request to the senior leadership team
to look again at the risk and to widen
it out in terms of the debate that's
happened this morning particularly
around
the wider district and not just the
council's carbon emissions
and then the second part of that
recommendation is to the cabinet because
the cabinet are monitoring performance
with
the climate change action plan so it's
to them to say that you've identified
some additional risk and you would like
some assurance
as a committee from the cabinet that
appropriate steps are being taken to
mitigate that risk and deliver on those
ambitions in the action plan
just with regards to the planning bit
i
totally take on board the comments of
the chair of joint overview and scrutiny
committee
and i think that's entirely appropriate
about understanding whether an imp
any impact can be made by review from
the committee
it might just be
sensible perhaps to ask the chief
planning officer to just
provide the advice that went to the
planning committee to all members so
that you've all got an opportunity to
have a look at that and just understand
the limitations within the the planning
system
with regards to climate change
thank you emily i think all members did
have that advice certainly on baber i
certainly did i'm not sure if it
actually applies to um
the problem um i raised about bussing
children out i think that was a
member decision that one but um yeah
well we have a good steer i'm sure that
uh henrietta has minuted our concerns um
counter emerson and councillor barrett
next
thank you
um yeah i'd just like to ask again what
what mechanism might there be for uh
amplifying this
in the community and
to other stakeholders because it seems
that we might just be again keeping it
within the council and
in these walls so
um
i think this just you know
at the risk of just being back in the
same place again
in a year's time
um
we need to
make it part of the uh
you know public conversation so can we
have any outreach or
external communications in terms of
the position that the council finds
itself in
council ramerson is um going out on
youtube so i think you've certainly made
um your point clear as have all of us um
councillor barrett
yeah i one of the things i think we can
do and um possibly is um
ask that when and if there are changes
to the current building regulations that
we as a council
are very um
up to date and we implement them as
speedly as possible
that's something that we can do so as
and when those changes come to the
criteria for that in terms of the carbon
neutral position which we're hoping to
achieve with the new bills
um as and when they come forward as part
of the statute then we as a council
implement them as quickly as possible
that's something we can do that's within
our gift and we can do that um
everything else is i'm afraid is outside
what we can do so we can as i say huff
and puff and blow the house down robert
but actually what we need to do is
things that we can actually achieve so
that is something when when those
changes come in what we do is we
implement them and all the counsellors
are up to date with that information as
quickly as possible and that's something
that we can put in the wrist switcher is
a tangible tangible action
i mean
we've got to be realistic about what we
can achieve
yeah it's quite right but things could
suddenly change
in november after the glasgow climate
change meeting there could be things
something like that
yeah yeah well i think that's as far as
we can get i'm sure that henriette has
admitted all this that we wish our
comments to go to the senior leadership
team and to cabinet
and say do you better lads
i think that's about where we've arrived
at
as of today
um
no this doesn't need noting does it
henry yet um let me just quick look
i guess it does need nothing doesn't it
it's just commenting the report
yes yeah and we don't need to have a
vote do we unless you want to make an
official a straight forward
recommendation to slt and cabinet yes
and do we need do we need to call a vote
on that yes you do okay
you're going to set that up then
so i would say that to approve the
recommendations by the chair of the
committee for the vote but it will be um
basically to recommend that the minutes
are
forwarded to slt in the cabinet yes
record what we've just said yep that's
perfect i do apologize
so i'm setting out a boat in the um
coming up now i've turned blue and
shortly i'm sure
absolutely sure of the exact
recommendations we're making could we
just um
i think emily read it out very
succinctly we're making a recommendation
to the senior leadership team
and also the cabinet
that we think we're in
significant risk of not meeting um the
targets that that were originally said
and we would like it
highlighted and and beefed up in my
words
all right okay thank you yeah which is
about all we can do i i can't see any
point in recommending it to scrutiny
because
we've got as far as we've got with that
yeah no you're just
thank you
i appreciate this committee doesn't have
huge powers what we do is mainly to look
at what's gone but
i think in this case we do have a chance
to influence what's coming and
um thank you everybody you've been
brilliant actually in doing that it's
it's it's not an easy one
can you put your microphone on mary yeah
sorry and a bit nearer because i know
i just wondered whether he's back i was
going to say we can't go for the vote
until the council lindsay's back
had you voted robert
council lindsay can i have your vote
please
four so that is uh seven votes for chair
uh eight votes for one that's carried
okay thank you
unanimous thank you um
gentlemen not an easy on paper ladies
and gentlemen but i think we did more
than um
we were expected
okay
and it's item um eight the annual audit
letter twenty one seven i'm very sorry
vicky on my original papers it um
it wasn't in that pack of the centers
are supplementary but i have glanced at
it so um
thank you very much for coming yes we
have met before i recognize you now
and um the floor is yours please
thank you chair and good morning
everyone and we issue an unqualified
opinion on both baby and mr fatkell and
a clean value for money conclusions on
28th of july following the conclusions
of them all
sure
is it better
yeah okay
and
following the conclusions of the order
there's a requirement to issue an an
audit letter summarizing the key
messages
and hence this letter that we bring to
the committee
so we already reported our detailed
findings
through the audit result report in march
committee and then final audit result
report on 15th of july a summary of this
issue can be found in this letter in the
executive summary sections
and also in page 9 of the letter ie page
36 and 41 in your pack
so there are no other new messages
in relation to the audit finding
and this letter is more of a
public-facing summary of what we had
previously discussed
and i also wanted to draw your
attentions to page 37 in the pack
that the completion certificate
was issued on the same date on 28th of
july not 27 november 2020
so that brings to the end of the paper
and i'm happy to take any questions that
you may have
okay thank you very much vicky
questions members
please
oh it looks as if you're getting off
quite lightly councillor lindsay
so this may have come up in earlier
in the last meeting or but um
the the um
the investment property
right down over a million pounds in
beaver
what property was that for
uh that was borham gate uh shopping
center
and what was it do you know i suppose
you don't have it with you but the total
value
and a forum gate
i haven't got the total value but i
believe that it was um
overstated by nearly a million so i
think it's bring it down to about two
million near to four million mark
sorry three millimark
i haven't got the d you know the actual
one from four to three yeah 43 about
that
figure
so it was overstated that property by
about a million
so
um
is that because we pay too much for it
no because what happens that um
investment property under the accounting
standard ifrs
um
through ifrs 613 you need to reverse
renew the property on an annual basis
because it's an investment property and
therefore it needs to be valued at the
highest and best use of the value which
is we call the fair value
so that property needs to go through the
annual
valuations
every year and what we found is that the
assumption used by the valuer
were not um supported by the marketable
data
and therefore because obviously when we
did our
audit work
we look at the assumption used by the
valuer and then we compare with a range
of assumptions that based on our
research and we found that you know some
of the assumption used is not supported
by the
observable market data
and that's why
we think it was overstated by nearly a
million
so it's not because you're paying too
much it's just that it's a valuation
exercise that you need to go through
every year to make sure that the
property is stated at the fair value on
your accounts
the obvious question is what did we pay
for it
i would need to go back and check now
actually a few years ago we yeah we
bought it so yeah i'll check and confirm
that figure
so just to summarize we bought it for
3.2 but we had it on the books for about
four
and and and that you found that that's a
bit
that's the wrong figure to have it on
the books and we should have it at about
three
yeah so okay so yeah all right
if that's
thanks
any more questions on this paper
just the general one vicki um
said there's a death of
um auditors and the market is suffering
is that still the case
um
obviously like kathryn says that you
know um the pandemic the impact pandemic
is still ongoing
um
it's still quite early to judge that you
know what would have an impact on the
invest especially invest investment
property because it's a ritual
um sector
so
especially you know the change of
behavior of the consumers that's all
have impact like you know how to attract
um businesses to operate in shopping
center for example so that will have an
impact on the market value of the
property
and but this is ongoing things that you
know it's still something that you know
we need to see how it panned out
um
during academic year i was mainly
talking about um
staff shortages to do the job you know
because um
you know
the audit seems to get late and it's
always blamed on lack of people to do it
it seems nationally we're short of
auditors and tanker drivers doesn't it
but um it's just a general question
are you attracting
more people to do the job a bit quicker
we we are we
we would say that you know um
the circumstances is kind of improving
but like you say that you know um
pandemic is still playing the impact
into the whole situations so
we are still recruiting we are still you
know bringing up our people but there
are other impacts like you know result
from the pandemics like for example
additional work that we have to do and
the comp
complexity that it adds to the border as
well so this all
you know kind of
still have an impact on the audit
okay
nothing else on this paper
um
thank you very much for attending
see you again thank you
on to the forward plan
in your pack countless um i did make a
comment we're a bit
uh light in this meeting um
the meetings coming up we're all happy
with what
no concerns about what we're doing and
the upcoming agenda
the only concerns that i have is that
the meetings
you know
it's just about noting isn't it
i know that our notes can then be taken
to cabinet and whatever
but
to pull in all of us counsellors just
for noting i just feel sometimes we
probably maybe you ought to
have these meetings less frequently and
have them so we have a meatier agenda
it just strikes me that we're sort of we
get it's almost if we're trying to put a
put an agenda together to get to justify
having a meeting
um and then then the content i mean
constantly really is
i don't feel we're making any real
contribution
um
until such times that we have actually
something to discuss and it just strikes
me that to have joint meetings about
uh noting uh the auditor's report which
is very noble and nicely beautiful
graphics by the way
um it may manage to keep you looking at
it a little bit longer
um i just think we just need a bit more
meat on the bone mr chairman
i think to be honest um council about
it's a different sort of committee we're
looking at what's happened and checking
and it's obviously important that we do
that um
we are the checking function on what's
gone by especially on financial matters
so it is important whether our influence
is that major probably not but it's
still a vital function
councillor lindsay and counter amazon
well i didn't have anything to say on
the forward i was just just to comment
on because i i kind of totally know
where
counselor is coming from you know it's
quite
driving and
it genders that sort of
you know i think that we can't if we
could do it online it would be different
but having to but but um on the other
hand
um you know i've been to audit
committees where
it's been that high you know and that is
too much but if you put it all together
and and the officers can't possibly know
what we're going to suddenly pick up and
have a big debate about what we're not
um
and
and i think things like that the um
the risk register i do actually quite
um
actually with hindsight now we've had
the meeting i i think it's worth having
a meeting just about the risk register
it is
it's kind of a thought exercise and
perhaps the job of the audit committee
is to kind of think about what could
possibly go wrong and
and highlight areas and
you know
i mean
if if nothing if if if we're not
listened to then that's something else
that's a different problem from the
forward diary that's
that's a problem with this
you know of the structure of the council
or something if what our recommendations
today aren't are ignored by cabinet and
ignored by the slt i'm sure they won't
be but if they are then we'll have
things to say at the next meeting you
know
thank you chair um so yeah just to uh
add to this
question of our effectiveness
uh obviously we put a recommendation
forward regarding the
uh risk register
about um you know doing better
so
what's the mechanism there will will
there be a response from the slt can we
expect a response of this meet at this
cabinet yes we also made a
recommendation about investments into
fossil fuels and moving away from it and
that's going through you see we did and
that was two that was two meetings ago
that was the one in march i believe yeah
and we we
i was gonna raise this at this meeting i
don't know if this is the appropriate
time to do it
but
our recommendation read something like
let's really look at
the
investments and and
look at being proactive in finding
funds and invest portfolios that are
that are progressive in their in their
outlook and looking at new markets new
technologies sun rising industries
rather than sunsetting
and there was a footnote at the end of
it to say
but it should be financially prudent and
it seems as though
at the last
mid suffolk uh full council meeting i
don't know about what happened to baber
but
um
it was
uh revealed to the council that
basically there's no move on that and
and it was because of this uh issue with
financial prudence
supposedly however during that march
meeting
uh
myself and uh councillor lindsay and
others
pointed out that
there's two ways to look at the
financial prudence there's the there's
the there's the loss of changing
the funds
but there's also the uh the risk in
holding on to such funds as we do
uh in terms of sunsetting industries so
i was a bit shocked and a bit
disappointed that
that was seem to have been glanced over
and
no movement had been made on that and so
i wanted to ask at some point
um
when that might happen and
what's the latest thinking on that but i
don't know who can answer
okay thank you councillor casper
um i just wanted to um
just because
just because we've had um one meeting
that's a bit shorter and a little bit
less subject matter
um we've got two
very well written
reports on there we've just finished
treasury management which was a huge
document that we spent a lot of time on
we've got an am audit on there that's
extremely well done and we don't have
many issues with it enjoy that we still
need to
do it it needs to come through this um
committee because it's the checks and
the balances that we need
in this council because it even if we do
um 10 things that we find
nothing wrong with that 11th one is it's
so important that we pick that up um and
as
all i wanted to say is yeah enjoy it
because
looking at the forward plan we've got a
lot of work coming up so um
let's um
let's enjoy having a short meeting and i
can't remember when the last really
short meeting was
a while back
councilman mclaren before i bring in the
officers
yeah thank you chair um well i come from
a background of
regulation and
i think
holding
the council
and the function of the council to
account is important
it's the same as scrutiny we have got to
have subjects that we can
make a difference to
but i think
sometimes the forward plans seem to be
routine and
is there a possibility that items can
come up in this meeting that
perhaps are not routinely on the plan
but i do think i do believe in order and
standards and i believe in overview and
scrutiny i think
we've got councils have got to be a bit
more rigorous in their questioning
and um
you know looking at like as i mentioned
earlier you know the risk is about
people that systems fit building and we
need to be exploring those aspects of
risk of
scrutiny whichever
you want to look at
thank you joe
thank you
councillor mclaren no other comments um
catherine john can you reassure us
please that counselor barrett is not
wasting his talents and not in the rest
of us our time
i would just reiterate what one or two
of you have said actually about the
importance of
you know this committee holding the
council to account you know in in the
matters that you've been given the remit
over in terms of your you know your
terms of reference for this particular
committee so you know i think it is
important in terms of you know risk
financial management the audit reports
and also the standards side of it as
well
i think it does tend to be more of a
routine committee than perhaps overview
and scrutiny
because of those things that happen
throughout the year that you need to
keep you know those checks and balances
on but
i'd certainly
value the input from the committee in
terms of you know what we're producing
and the challenge that you give us back
as officers
and catherine for my own benefit and
councillor ambrose and could you just
say where our um
feelings on the change in the investment
policy um have got to i know they've
been reported to cabinets and
just an update would be helpful yeah
what i was going to say is that just
looking at the forward plan the next
meeting in november we've got the half
year report on treasury management so
that would probably feel like a good
point to include something in that
report for you
thank you you're happy with that
yep
good good councillor mueller
i'd just like to actually comment um
i think we're very fortunate in this
particular council that for several
years now we've had unqualified audit
reports
and that does mean you know the the
council has been shown through its
internal audit and external audit
procedures for doing things correctly
um i hop back to when i personally have
worked in in the past for department of
health audit and also the audit
commission and i don't recall one
instance when we actually had an
unqualified report
and obviously if we are in that
situation i'm sure we'll be debating
individual areas of audit in much more
detail
if we were failing in any particular
area so i think the officers
and the staff who are involved in this
financial thing have done an excellent
job
several years to have unqualified audit
reports that is a good achievement
believe me thank you
yeah so you're here thank you for that
councillor barrow
i come from a totally different
background so i would love to see your
qualified reports because then you push
the boundaries of actually what you're
doing if you're happy to sit there and
you're totally um
risk averse then clearly that's what
you're going to get but then when you
risk averse you end up with
no money uh sitting there wondering how
it's all going to happen
but then that's my background you see
i think business and local government is
slightly different simon
thank you for your input i think that
sounds like the end of the meeting to me
um we don't need to vote on this do we
know that's all done thank you so much
um see you in november
you